und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend in den vier sekunden den sie
mir bis hier hin zugehört haben wurden
auf der welt circa 16 kinder geboren
acht menschen starben die
weltbevölkerung ist also um acht
menschen angewachsen
dieses wachstum stand im mittelpunkt der
welt bevölkerungs konferenz die heute in
der obi zu ende gingen drei tage lang
diskutierten experten aus 160 ländern
darüber was das für unseren globus
bedeutet wie viele menschen verkraftet
die erde und wie wird sich das
bevölkerungswachstum weiterentwickeln
die prognose sind da keineswegs so
eindeutig die menschheit wächst zwar
insgesamt weiter aber nicht mehr so
schnell wie in früheren dekaden in
großen teilen der erde schrumpft die
bevölkerung nämlich längst nicht nur in
europa auch in asien und einigen ländern
südamerikas
viel wird davon abhängen wie sich afrika
entwickelt tim krüger berichtet in
dieser klinik in nairobi slum kibera
wegen junge frauen über verhütungsmittel
aufgeklärt und mit medikamenten versorgt
die 21 jährige für ihre team og nie ist
bereits mutter möchte nun aber bewusst
darüber entscheiden wie viele kinder sie
bekommt wir waren als kinder zu acht
aber ich möchte nicht so viele wie meine
mutter denn es gibt große
herausforderungen heute es kostet viel
geld viele kinder groß zu ziehen und
später gibt es kaum jobmöglichkeiten das
pure timo genii diese entscheidung
bewusst treffen kann ist ein
hoffnungsschimmer mir nicht dennoch gibt
es in afrika zu viele geschichten wie
die der 39-jährigen carolina in einem
kleinen verschlag liebt sie mit ihren
kindern das erste bekam sie mit 13
als sie später heiratete bekam sie noch
einmal sechs kinder bis ihr mann sie
sitzen ließ jetzt kämpft sie täglich ums
überleben
die nahezu jeden morgen wenn ich
aufwache weiß ich nicht was die kinder
essen sollen vielleicht etwas haar
verbreitet zu mittag
ich versuche alles oft schaffe ich es
nicht dann leihe ich mir etwas damit die
kinder nicht hungrig zu bett gehen
müssen
frauen wie carolina chiang sollen
gestärkt werden durch mehr informationen
und zugang zu verhütungsmitteln durch
bessere bildung und perspektiven das ist
das ziel der weltbevölkerung konferenz
die heute in euro wii zu ende gegangen
ist weltweit sinken die geburtenraten
zwar aber allein in subsahara afrika
gibt es noch immer fast 20 millionen
ungewollte schwangerschaften pro jahr
durch bildung verstehen junge frauen
besser wie sie verhüten können
sie können weiter zur schule gehen und
fürs heiraten verhindern dass immer noch
in vielen ländlichen gegenden in
subsahara afrika stattfindet armut
mangelnde bildung das sind laut
marketingleiter vom nationalrat für
bevölkerung und entwicklung die gründe
dafür dass auch in china noch immer
menschen keinen zugang zu
verhütungsmitteln haben
und wenn man investiert um den
lebensstandard der eigenen familie zu
verbessern macht es keinen sinn viele
kinder zu haben
die geburten abstände müssen größer sein
damit weniger kinder geboren werden um
die man sich dann kümmern kann
weltweit hat sich das
bevölkerungswachstum in den vergangenen
jahren abgeschwächt etwas auch in afrika
dennoch könnte sich die zahl der
menschen auf dem jungen kontinent bis
2050 verdoppeln
aber themen wie verhütung und auch das
recht auf abtreibung sind gerade in
afrika mit seinen zum teil traditionell
geprägten ländern noch immer ein
sensibles fast zehn milliarden dollar
haben länder und private institutionen
auf der konferenz in nairobi für die
stärkung von frauen und mädchen zugesagt
jeder muss zugang zu modernen
verhütungsmethoden haben es darf keine
vermeidbarer müttersterblichkeit mehr
geben und 0 gewalt gegen frauen bis 2030
noch haben mehr als 200 millionen frauen
weltweit gar keinen zugang zu moderner
familienplanung das
weltbevölkerungswachstum insgesamt hängt
natürlich auch mit besserer
medizinischer versorgung zusammen man
denke etwa daran wie viele menschen
früher durch epidemien hinweggerafft
wurden an der so genannten großen test
in europa starben im achtzehnten
jahrhundert innerhalb weniger jahre eine
million menschen angesichts eines
solchen traumas wundert es nicht dass im
achtzehnten jahrhundert in europa auch
der erste impfstoff entwickelt wurde
gegen pocken in asien war man zu der
zeit übrigens schon viel weiter
dort hatte man schon in der antike
begonnen mit pocken erregern zu
experimentieren
in deutschland wurde 1874 nach einer
pocken epidemie mit mehr als 180 tausend
toten die erste in pflicht eingeführt
unter androhung hoher strafen und auch
damals gab es schon ins gegner mit
anderen worten das thema ist keineswegs
neu zur heutigen entscheidung des
bundestags eine masernimpfung
einzuführen ein bericht von petra und im
moment ob er mag oder nicht dieser peaks
ist pflicht ab märz 2020 müssen alle
kinder in kitas und schulen zweimal
gegen masern geimpft sein
genauso die beschäftigten dort und in
wegen kliniken nachzuweisen durch den
impfausweis für den gesundheitsminister
ist das der richtige weg um die masern
bald auszurotten hart durchgreifen keine
toleranz für impfgegner wenn ich im
übrigen einige hörer die sagen ist täte
den kindern ganz gut
weil eine solche erkrankung durch zu
machen dann ist das auch eine form von
körperverletzung weil jeder unnötige
infektion vor allem mit einer krankheit
die auch so bösartig verlaufen kann ist
ihm eine gefährdung von leib und leben
mehr als 500 masernfälle bis jetzt in
diesem jahr in deutschland vermeidbar
wären mindestens 95 prozent der
bevölkerung geimpft doch die quote wird
seit jahren nicht erreicht trotz
kampagnen baden württemberg ist
schlusslicht nur knapp 90 prozent sind
hier geimpft
auch sie hat mit sich gerungen vor allem
nach der ersten impfung am anfang war es
dann schon so dass er erst mal eine
heftige reaktion gezeigt hat
das hat uns auch verunsichert aber im
großen und ganzen denke ich einfach für
uns der richtige weg masern eine
kinderkrankheit mit manchmal schweren
komplikationen die impfung dagegen gilt
als sicher und gut verträglich es gibt
so gut wie keine nachgewiesenen
impfschäden die kinderärzte fast alle
impfbefürworter aber impfzwang ich bin
ein bisschen traurig dass es so ist das
ist nötig ist weil wir haben eigentlich
so viele gute argumente für die
masernimpfung dass man sich wirklich
fragt auch ist wirklich dieses gesetz
die elternschaft beim thema impfzwang
alles andere als eindeutig prinzipiell
finde ich das gut
weil der defekt die gesundheit natürlich
vorgeht mein kind das auch gleich
geimpft hier zwangsgelder weiß ich nicht
ich finde nicht dass die politik das
recht hat uns eltern das vorzuschreiben
das motivieren und das muss mein kind
nicht zu führen
die skeptiker lassen sich wohl eher
wenig beeindrucken durch das neue maß an
schutz gesetz zu den vielen
nebenwirkungen des internets gehört ja
auch dass sich das reisen verändert hat
der nicht den wirklich abgelegene
weltgegenden aufbricht kann sich vorher
von zu hause aus praktisch schon alles
an bis zum letzten strandkorb sozusagen
selbst für den körnung grad des landes
in dem er steht findet sich in den
tiefen des netzes sicher irgendwo ein
erfahrungsbericht
besonders beliebt sind hotelbewertungen
auch das ein phänomen
man vertraut auf das urteil von menschen
die man überhaupt nicht kennt das kann
zwar funktionieren stichwort
schwarmintelligenz aber wenigstens
sollten die menschen die solche
bewertung und schreiben auch real
existieren und tatsächlich dort gewesen
sein
das münchner landgericht hat heute ein
urteil gefällt gegen sogenannte fake
bewertungen
mehr dazu von felix zimmermann wenn
jemand eine reise bucht so verlässt er
sich oft auf bewertung anderer reisender
aus dem internet dort werden in den
schönsten worten traum mitteln
versprochen doch die realität sieht oft
ganz anders aus
überfüllte strände dreckige zimmer
schmutzige pool tägliches essen
dabei sollen doch die erfahrungsberichte
aus dem internet genau solche bösen
überraschungen verhindern
mehr als die hälfte der deutschen liest
online bewertungen und entscheidet sich
erst dann für ein produkt ein
restaurantbesuch oder eben eine
urlaubsreise die leute mit denen mit den
reisen zufrieden waren bevor ich das
buch so dass doch das beste finde ich wo
man also wenn man fest machen kann ob
das jetzt auch sich lohnt das dahin zu
gehen da positive erfahrungsberichte den
verbraucher beeinflussen sind sie bares
geld wert und so ist die versuchung
mancher unternehmen groß diese zu
fälschen und damit kunden anzulocken
dienstleister wie five star machen sich
das zunutze und bieten herstellern
händlern restaurantbesitzern positive
bewertungen zum kauf an
diese werden dann im internet auf amazon
google und anderen portalen verbreitet
auch hoteliers konnten über fester
lobende erfahrungsberichte einfach
kaufen angebliche gäste bewerteten
hotels die sie nie betreten hatten
das landgericht münchen hat dieses
geschäftsmodell heute verboten es
bedeutet zum einen darauf dass die five
star keine bewertungen mehr anbieten
darf denen kein tatsächlicher aufenthalt
des bewerbers zu grunde liegt außerdem
muss die feier auch nach auskunft
erteilen und eine löschung veranlassen
dieser bewertungen geklagt hatte das
reiseportal holidaycheck für das
unternehmen hat die wahrheit der
bewertungen hohe priorität
kunden vertrauen auf die meinung anderer
urlauber und wir wollen alles dafür tun
dass sich die kunden auch auf die
bewertung im internet verlassen können
es ist das erste mal dass eine
buchungsplattform von sich aus gegen
falsche bewertung erfolgreich klagt
julia berger von der verbraucherzentrale
münchen hofft dass das urteil
signalwirkung hat wir würden uns
wünschen dass viele plattformen hier
nachziehen und mehr gegen gefälschte
bewertungen unternehmen bislang gehen
internetgiganten wie amazon oder google
allenfalls zögerlich gegen die fälscher
von kritiken vor
und so gibt es sie weiterhin im internet
massenhaft erfundene bewertungen
und jetzt auch erstmal ein 12 weiter mit
anderen meldungen des tages
der solidaritätszuschlag ursprünglich
für den aufschwung ost eingeführt soll
nun abgebaut werden
der bundestag hat heute eine neue
regelung beschlossen nach der der soli
für rund 90 prozent der zahler ab 2021
ganz wegfällt
das sind beispielsweise singles mit
einem jahresbrutto von höchstens etwa
73.000 900 euro bei einer familie mit
zwei kindern gilt das bis etwa 152.000
euro
bei denjenigen die mehr verdienen wird
der zuschlag nach der höhe gestaffelt
erhoben
derzeit liegt er bei 5 5 prozent der
körperschaft und einkommensteuer
die türkei hat wie angekündigt damit
begonnen ausländische mutmaßliche
anhänger und islamisten in ihre
heimatländer abzuschieben
eine siebenköpfige familie kam am abend
in berlin an die familie aus
niedersachsen wird dem salafistischen
milieu zugerechnet
offen ist ob sie etwas mit dem es zu tun
hatte zwischen israel und der
extremistengruppe islamischer dschihad
im gazastreifen gilt seit dem morgen
eine waffenruhe
allerdings feuerten militante
palästinenser bis zum abend nach
armeeangaben noch vereinzelt raketen auf
israel ab in den beiden tage zuvor
hatten die extremisten hunderte raketen
auf israel abgefeuert und die
israelische armee beschoss ziele im
gazastreifen
in bolivien geht der machtkampf auch
nach dem rücktritt von präsident morales
weiter
morales der inzwischen in mexiko im exil
ist bezeichnete die ernennung von vize
parlamentspräsidentin an jetzt so seine
nachfolgerin als bruch der verfassung
es gab auch erneut auseinandersetzungen
zwischen morales anhängern und gegnern
die zahl der toten bei den seit drei
wochen andauernden unruhen stieg
schon aufziehen zwei der schönsten
architektur ikonen des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts finden sich in berlin die
neue nationalgalerie von mies van der
rohe und die philharmonie von hans
schachl gefeierter architektur denkmäler
kühn entworfen führten sie bedienten die
moderne
leider stehen sie beide auf einem der
misslungene plätze berlins eine lehre
brache mit würstchenbude und parkplatz
das soll sich endlich ändern dort soll
ein neues museum für moderne kunst
gebaut werden ein wettbewerb wurde
ausgeschrieben und von stararchitekten
gewonnen
herzog & de meuron die auch die
hamburger elbphilharmonie entworfen
haben
so weit so gut doch nun gibt es eine
kulturpolitische debatte die heute auch
im bundestag ausgetragen wurde denn
überraschung
das bauprojekt wird viel teurer als
ursprünglich veranschlagt stefanie draws
bericht
hier im dunkeln wartet unschätzbare
kunst auf ihr museum dalí picasso
beckmann 4000 werke der moderne
staatsbesitz im keller zwischen national
gallery und philharmonie soll nun
endlich ihre museum des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts entstehen konzipiert haben
es die stararchitekten die schon die
elbphilharmonie entwarfen nach jahren
soll der bau nun beginnen
teurer als geplant jetzt können wir
endlich die kunst dieses zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts angemessen präsentieren
auch eine kulturpolitikerin muss
schlucken wie teuer bauen heutzutage ist
erst recht dann werden wir für
anspruchsvolle kunst die entsprechende
museum errichten denn schon vor dem
spatenstich verdoppelten sich die
baukosten auf geschätzte 450 millionen
ein grund der denkmalschutz für die
anliegende matthäuskirche im ersten
entwurf rückte das museum der kirche zu
nah nun soll schmaler und tiefer gebaut
werden eingeplant ein weiteres stockwerk
bis unter den wasserpegel die kosten
keine überraschung meint der architekt
werden
da muss man sich vorstellt da kannst du
nicht ein gebäude machen das einfach
wieder die einfache blechle ist das
prestige-projekt lange zankapfel
entweder geliebt oder verspottet
dabei ist eines unstrittig berlin
braucht ein museum der moderne und die
brach am kulturforum ist eine chance zu
beweisen dass auch die hauptstadt
leuchttürme der kunst errichten kann
heute genehmigte der bund rund 364
millionen euro
doch nicht alle unterstützen dies einen
vorsichtigen haushälter ist die
schmerzgrenze da schon überschritten
deswegen hat die fdp her auch nicht
mitgestimmt mit den anderen fraktionen
das tut schon weh aber wir müssen auch
akzeptieren dass wenn ein solcher mehr
als beschluss ist dann muss eben genau
kontrolliert werde
kosten und bau sollen daher halbjährlich
überprüft werden da sind sich alle einig
sind natürlich schon willens die
kritiker zu überzeugen dass es ein
großartiges gebäude ist dass es auch in
dieser dimension notwendig ist um die
kunst entsprechend dort zu präsentieren
was aber auch klar ist dass die summe
die bereitgestellt wurde unser extrem
verpflichtet vor allem die
bauverantwortlichen mithin ganz ganz
enges kostenmanagement durchzuführen in
sieben jahren soll das museum des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts hier seine
türen öffnen
ob es bei den angestrebten kosten
bleiben wird die bauherren zumindest
glauben fest daran ja was läuft dabei
großen architektur projekten immer
wieder häufig schief darüber wollen wir
mit einem großen deutschen architekten
sprechen mit volkwin marg gemeinsam mit
meinhard von gerkan gründete er eines
der einflussreichsten architekturbüros
hierzulande zu dessen projekten unter
anderem der berliner hauptbahnhof und
der berüchtigte flughafen ber gehört
guten abend herr professor marc guten
abend sie haben jahrzehntelange
erfahrung mit großprojekten auch mit
kulturbauten diese 200 millionen euro
die für den museumsbau in berlin
ursprünglich mal veranlagt waren waren
die ihrer einschätzung nach jemals
realistisch ja die waren realistisch und
die sind auch sehr korrekt ermittelt
worden nämlich vom bundesamt für bau und
raumordnung nach volumens untersuchung
und unter berücksichtigung zu
erwartender kostensteigerung nach dem
index dem baukostenindex mit dem ziel
jahr 2025
aber warum jetzt gehen die dann jetzt
plötzlich so nach oben jetzt ist von 450
millionen geräte man ahnt es wird am
ende noch vielmehr weil im grunde
genommen der standort gewechselt wurde
entgegen allen empfehlungen diese
empfehlung
kam ja nicht nur vom bundesamt für bauen
raumordnung
die nämlich genau diesen jetzigen
standort kritisch in frage stellten
sondern auch vom präsidenten der
stiftung preußischer kulturbesitz von
herrn professor parzinger
das heißt also es wurde quasi nach dem
entwurf der architekten wurden dann noch
gewaltige veränderungen vorgenommen zum
beispiel nach an sandra standort nein
nein der standort wurde vor dem
wettbewerb bereits geändert wieder an
der empfehlung und es wurde dann
natürlich auch das programm erweitert
und geändert
das ist etwas was zum beispiel auch die
architekten kollegen von ihnen herzog
und dämmerung der dieses museum in
berlin aufbauen dann auch bei der
elbphilharmonie erzählt haben dann hat
er anfangs eine kaffeetasse und dann
sollte aber auch noch ein unterteller
dazu kommen und ein löffel und gewaltige
veränderungen die von den bauherren
gewünscht werden ist das typisch bei
solchen öffentlichen projekten
es ist typisch dass man normalerweise
tief stapelt um kosten bewilligt zu
bekommen parlamentarisch oder durch
bürgerschaft oder wie auch immer
und darf man dann hofft dass sanieren zu
können wenn das gebäude steht wie das ja
auch etwa beim flughafen in
berlin-schönefeld der fall war
da war es ja von vornherein ein viel zu
niedriges budget und die baumassen hatte
sich quasi verdoppelt im laufe der zeit
und wurde dann auch unendlich häufig
geändert in die funktion da waren sie
nun ihr büro selbst beteiligt warum
haben sie denn dann als als architekten
als büro nicht laut protestierten gesagt
das geht auf gar keinen fall so haben
ganze romane geschrieben wir haben rot
gelb grün waren sitzen gehabt wir haben
hunderte von von von stop signalen gab
die wurden ignoriert es dass eines der
kernprobleme das zu wenig geplant wird
bevor es dann an die ausschreibungen
geht also für konkrete baufirmen etc
parat um uns im falle berlin sagen dass
er wohl vorher sorgfältig geschätzt
wurde als man noch gar kein entwurf
hatte man hat er nämlich
die nutzfläche und man hatte das volumen
geschätzt auch dass man ins wasser bauen
musste und man hat damals schon das
wahrhaben jahre 2013 ein ein betrag
geschätzt
der eigentlich doppelt so hoch ist wie
der dem man normalerweise für ein
solches volumen einsetzen würde und dann
sogar noch den indie index steigerung
berücksichtigt also da hat man keinen
fehler gemacht es ist deutlich teurer
geworden weil man die ungünstigste
standort gewählt hat bei anti ften auch
liegt das betrifft auch das grundwasser
erstens zweitens mann hat offensichtlich
das programm gewechselt und drittens es
schert öffentlich niemanden der
baustandard denn je nachdem welchem
baustandard man realisiert kostet es mir
also eine besondere architektur kostet
dann eben auch mehr geld muss nicht tut
sie aber dann danke schön herr professor
mark für das gespräch aus ihrer
perspektive und ihren ansichten
widersprechen wir aus termingründen am
abend aufgezeichnet und mit den
wirtschaften finanzen geht es bereits
weiter
die deutsche wirtschaft hat nach einem
rückgang im ersten quartal des jahres in
den sommermonaten wieder zugelegt um 0,1
prozent teilte das statistische
bundesamt mit durch diesen anstieg ist
eine rezession verhindert worden von der
sprechen volkswirte wenn es zwei -
quartale in folge gibt zu den großen
unternehmen in deutschland gehört
daimler und da gab es die netzhäute
neues zur weiteren strategie er seit
einem halben jahr hat ola källenius als
vorstandsvorsitzender bei daimler das
sagen der knapp zwei meter große schwede
verordnet dem konzern eine radikalkur
und setzt den rotstift an
für den betriebsrat ist das
unverhältnismäßig für investoren noch zu
wenig die daimler aktie verliert heute
an der frankfurter börse viereinhalb
prozent daimler kämpft mit altlasten wie
den diesel skandal rückrufen und
bußgeldern
nun setzen die strenger werdenden co2
bestimmungen der eu daimler unter druck
der konzern muss mehr elektro und hybrid
autos produzieren um die vorgaben zu
erfüllen
konkurrent tesla belebt zwar das
geschäft verschärft aber auch den druck
kollege bmw hat deutlich weniger
beschäftigte in der autosparte bis zum
ende des jahres 2022 sollen nun bei
daimler alleine beim personal rund 1,4
milliarden euro gespart werden
jede zehnte stelle im management soll
wegfallen
doch auch bei der forschung und
entwicklung heißt es kosten senken
investitionen kappen und die vielfalt an
modellen reduzieren
die automobilbranche steht vermutlich
vor dem größten umbau ihrer geschichte
daimler hielt lange an alten mustern
fest und muss sich nun verändern und
anpassen
doch ein flaggschiff der deutschen
autoindustrie lässt sich nicht von heute
auf morgen runderneuert das ist ein
langer prozess der nun in vollem gange
ist
sina mainitz vielen dank bei der fahrer
wm der leichtathleten in dubai hat es
heute noch eine bronze medaille für das
deutsche team gegeben
alias ihn links im bild kam im 200 meter
lauf in der kategorie der beidseitig
oberschenkel amputiert
auf platz drei hinter der konkurrenz aus
südafrika und großbritannien
nächstes ziel für den 31-jährigen die
paralympics in tokio in köln ist der
hanns joachim friedrichs preis verliehen
worden er geht in diesem jahr an die
wissenschaftsjournalisten harald lesch
und martin kind beiden gelinge es sowohl
im fernsehen als auch auf youtube
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
verständlich zu machen und sie in
politische diskussionen einzuordnen so
die begründung der jury
der astrophysiker harald lesch ist unter
anderem bei leschs kosmos im zdf zu
sehen
die chemikerin martinique im bdr und
aufgaben youtube kanälen
gott existiert ihr name ist petra der
filmtitel lässt schon ahnen hier geht es
um rebellion
eine frau bringt in eine männerdomäne
ein und landet zur strafe in der hölle
ihre fälle liegt in mazedonien und
obwohl der film in der gegenwart spielt
wirken manche szenen wie aus dem
mittelalter mit einem tobenden mob der
auf hexenjagd geht gott existiert ihr
name ist geht rooney war auf der letzten
berlinale ein großer erfolg heute ist
wer in den deutschen kinos angelaufen
lohnenswert findet auch nadja nasa pedro
nia ist anfang dreißig ledig arbeitslos
und wieder einmal auf dem weg zu einem
vorstellungsgespräch aber in ihrer nord
mazedonischen kleinstadt ist ihr diplom
in geschichte nicht gerade gefragt und
eine frau wie sie schon gar nicht ich
dachte du wirst
und du wirst du hässlich
auf dem heimweg gerät sie in die
prozession zum christlich orthodoxen
dreikönigstag
wie jedes jahr wird ein geweihtes kreuz
in den fluss geworfen
wer es heraus fischt habe das ganze jahr
lang glück heißt es das dumme dieses
ritual ist nur für männer ihr spontaner
sprung der beginn eines handfesten
skandal
tatsächlich wird dieser brauch in jedem
dorf jeder stadt mazedoniens praktiziert
und weit darüber hinaus es geht dabei
auch immer darum seine männlichkeit zu
beweisen nach dem motto welcher toller
kerl schnappt sich das kreuz petronio
wird festgenommen und sogar das
fernsehen berichtet über ihren fall
sie soll das kreuz wieder herausrücken
wird von allen seiten unter druck
gesetzt aber petronio lässt sich nicht
beirren
während sich vor der polizeistation ein
wütender mob versammelt der teufel in
person ist
sie hat unser kreuz gestorben wir
brauchen einen wandel wir müssen uns und
unsere gesellschaft neu bewerten
vor allem im hinblick auf das
patriarchat und wir müssen mutiger
werden vor allem auch die männer von
ihnen erwarte ich den mut diese immer
absurder wirkenden altertümlichen
verhaltensweisen endlich abzulehnen
der film beruht auf einer wahren
begebenheit aus dem jahr 2014
es ist die schon fast grotesk anmutende
geschichte einer frau die sich etwas
nimmt das bisher nur männern vorbehalten
war und damit eine regelrechte hexenjagd
auslöst habe ich etwas
ein recht darauf glücklich zu sein gott
existiert ihr name ist pedro nia ist ein
beeindruckender film der einblick gibt
in ein land hin und hergerissen zwischen
verkrusteten strukturen und dem wunsch
nach aufbruch und ein eindringliches
plädoyer für gerechtigkeit und
emanzipation eine frau die auf jede
menge pöbeleien und hass im netz auf
sich ziehen würde
um hate speech und meinungsfreiheit geht
es gleich bei maybrit illner und um 0.30
gibt es dann heute plus mit daniel
bröckerhoff und uns gibt seine augen
wieder auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die großwetterlage ist derzeit
recht interessant wir haben ein massives
hoch im osten europas und das blockiert
den weg der tiefste müssen weit in den
süden runter rauschen sehen das tief bei
den britischen inseln das zieht richtung
spanien und dann in den mittelmeerraum
ja und es sorgt feuchte luft an die
drückt gegen die alpen und es gibt
ergiebige schneefälle in den nächsten
tagen und dazu wieder sturm an der adria
morgen und am sonntag wenn man genauer
hinschaut sieht man sogar den jetstream
dahinter der erreicht nämlich einmal
weit in den süden und weit in den norden
also derart schon wieder auch sehr stark
hin und er schauen wir in die nacht im
süden wird es ruhig sein
hier bildet sich nebel ansonsten im
norden ebenfalls ruhig nur der vans der
stramm aus östlichen richtungen bei
temperaturen von minus drei grad am
alpenrand und plus vier grad an der
ostsee hier wirbt wärmt das meer noch
ein wenig nach
morgen im tagesverlauf kommen im süden
mehr wolken an in den alpen schneit es
nach norden in richtung meint setzt sich
der regen durch aber auch nicht viel
weiter sonst ist es trocken und
weiterhin starker wind aus östlichen
richtungen
bei temperaturen von maximal vier grad
an den alpen und 14 grad im südosten
die nächsten tage es wird am samstag im
nordwesten regnen dazu ist es sehr
windig aus südwest bei drei bis elf grad
die darauf folgenden tage sehen
weiterhin recht wechselhaft aus mit
weiterem regen und am montag wieder
schnee in den mittelgebirgen damit ein
schöner abend